these innocent victims of the sharp
cutting edge of the enemy's military
action have learned they can turn to us
for help support and security and to the
American serviceman it is equally clear
that the battles won with the sharp edge
of our own blade are only a beginning
ultimate victory in Vietnam will be won
through the people in the Civic action
that complements the military action
through our determined and skillful use
of the full blade
the concept of the full blade became a
reality
during the rice harvest along the
cambium ribbon a small number of village
farmers had asked for help they knew
that in a few nights
the Vietcong would come to take what
they needed in the form of a rice tanks
so the man of the 1st battalion 9th
Marines moved inland on an operation
called Golden Fleece a classic example
of civic action on the surface it might
have appeared that this was just another
grinding methodical patrol but in the
coming days the man of the 9th regiment
would not only save a rice crop they
would challenge more than a decade of
communist control with America's first
broad employment of the civic action
concept in the Far East
song cumbia a rich fertile and very
carefully cultivated battle there is a
proverb here that says every inch of
Earth is an inch of gold
it's nearly impossible to comprehend
what years of Vietcong terror and
exploitation can do to a Vietnamese
village one certain side-effect is
suspicion any man who stands in a
village street with a rifle over his arm
is a man to be feared
you
but fortunately for the farming people
of song combien there were others who
weren't afraid they told what they knew
about the Vietcong hiding-places talked
about the enemy's leaders the cutting
edge would come first
using village guides marine patrols
would push the Vietcong out of the
valley complex then villagers in the
area would be brought to a collection
point provided protection in their rice
fields during the harvest this would
strengthen the people's desire to help
themselves a basic ingredient in the
formula of security ambition and
self-respect that is the hallmark of the
full blame of civic action as the first
combat patrols went southward through
the tributaries of song cambium a theory
long held as gospel by the Communist
Capitol at Hanoi began to come apart at
the scenes the Americans might fight in
the Vietnamese countryside but any real
attempts at a genuine revolution in
health welfare and self-sufficiency
would be directed strictly toward the
struggling central government in Saigon
this was the American way of doing
things in the Far East it was this
postulate that the man of the ninth
regiment and their village guides began
to pull apart during the first moments
of contact with a Viet Cong stronghold
this is the benign face of terror in
South Vietnam to the farmers and
peasants he is a warrior of the
seven-headed dragons he operates best in
a small group close to where he was born
and raised in these natural surroundings
he has identified with and helped to
destroy all local governments of the
immediate countryside he has killed or
threatened to kill all who would speak
on behalf of the government in Saigon he
can hardly be expected to know the
meaning of the words self health
self-respect and self-realization 27 of
his kind and their stolen weapons of war
were captured by Marines during the
first day of military operations near
song combien but even then there were
areas of doubt one of the Vietcong
special talents is the ability to blend
into a crowd of innocent man
with their initial military objective
secured the Marines prepared to
implement the full blade if it could
liberate the hearts and minds of the
people of San Campion from old Viet Cong
influences if it could work in this
small corner of villages this second
face of war might one day spread over
all of South Vietnam
now it was first things first using our
immense resources of man machines and
medical know-how to care for those who
were emergent lead of immediate health
an assistance the enemy had neither the
capacity nor the desire to extend
well the men ashore there was still much
more to do their deeds in the coming
days would demonstrate to the Vietnamese
in fact that the democracy we take for
granted is more than idle political
theory for a people whose very existence
depends on the crops they cultivate the
most effective sort of civic action had
to be in the fields and rice paddies
where the Golden Fleece was ready for
harvest this wasn't the time to
challenge their ancient methods to
marvel at the truth machinery that has
served their hands for hundreds of years
the story of the harvesters and reapers
tools of our 20th century would come
later the important job was to bring in
the crop to safety away from the still
very real threat of Vietcong attack and
direct gangland-style collection of rice
tax attacks that in the past as amounted
to as much as 75% of the crop
to bring in the Golden Fleece of the
native harvest the same amphibious
tractors that had carried the American
serviceman into military action were
used now to implement this phase of the
civic action the people too had to be
brought in from the fields to the
collection point here they were given a
safe haven
while the diplomats in dungarees brought
to a conclusion of people-to-people
program that began 10,000 miles away in
the home churches and businesses of the
United States they carried out a program
which did more than words to dispel the
distrust borne of years of unfriendly
propaganda
there still were some doubting Thomases
but in Vietnam as everywhere else there
is still one sure route to the heart of
a man
you
for the little ones of course there is
no understanding of such words as
people-to-people and political
ideologies but the babies unfold to
warmth and kindness and food and with
the responsiveness of all children their
bigger brothers soon decide the people
the people concept should work both ways
nearby the rice was being stored away
with American servicemen and Vietnamese
people young and old working
side-by-side in the sort of cooperative
effort that is doing the most to put
forward our mission in Vietnam
to the Vietnamese every bit of the crop
is vital the straw of the rice stocks is
transformed into the mats on which they
sit the ropes to tie their bundles the
sandals on their feet even the roots
over their heads and every single grain
of rice is cherish
soldiers of the army of the Republic of
Vietnam and American officers worked
side by side in operation Golden Fleece
with the grain stored and the needs of
the flesh attended to it was time for
another phase of our civic action the
story translated into pictures of the
kind of help our technological advances
can provide during future harvests along
the cambium ribbon the same Amtrak that
carried out the fighting man and brought
in the grain became a crude but
effective motion picture theater to the
man who handed out the pamphlets that
amplified the story told by the film it
was clear that the villagers were
interested our positive action was
wiping away the generations old veneer
of distrust and doubt but whatever the
method whenever the harvest the rice
crop represents life itself to these
people of Vietnam certainly no Jason
ever found a more truly Golden Fleece
operation Golden Fleece was a classic
example of combined military and civic
action it's fulfilled aim was to
supplement the capabilities needs and
aspirations of a people so that one day
when we are gone
they will be able to carry on alone